Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Steeped in sensuality and sadism and cold-blooded dilettanteism. talking about the equally celebrated Italian writer Gabriele D'Annunzio, one of the greatest figures in modern Italian literature, a poet, a playwright, a novelist. And I suppose really in the, how would you describe him? In the last, well, the last two decades of the 19th century, perhaps he was, I mean, kind of faint echoes of Oscar Wilde. He was a dandy. He was a man who made a drama out of his own life. But far more than Wilde, he became a figure at the heart of seismic historical events. So in 1915, for instance, he engaged in incendiary speeches in the very heart of
感谢您收听《闲人 懂史》。如需每周获取独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目的抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社团，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这里充满着感官享乐、虐待狂倾向和冷血的业余爱好。我们正在谈论同样备受赞誉的意大利作家加布里埃尔·邓邓齐奥，他是现代意大利文学中最伟大的人物之一、诗人、剧作家、小说家。我想在——你会怎么形容他呢？在最后，嗯，19世纪的最后二十年，也许他是，我的意思是，有点像王尔德的微弱回声。他是个花花公子。他是一个把自己的生活过成一出戏的人。但与王尔德相比，他更多地成为了撼动历史事件核心的人物。因此，例如在1915年，他在
ancient Rome in the capital, persuading Italy to enter the Great War. In 1918, he led a dramatic air raid over Vienna. And in 1919, he set up effectively a city-state in the Croatian port of Fiume that was admired by both Lenin and Mussolini. And Mussolini, in fact, would go on to describe D'Annunzio as the John the Baptist of fascism. And Dominic, do you think is Mussolini onto something there in describing D'Annunzio, this extraordinary writer turned political leader as as the john the baptist of fascism i think he i think he was personally and i think um denunzio is um who you look to um if you want to find kind of exhibit a and how terrible writers often are as one of your favorite themes one of your favorites in particular
古罗马首都的中心发表了煽动性的演讲，说服意大利加入第一次世界大战。1918年，他领导了一次轰轰烈烈的维也纳空袭。1919年，他在克罗地亚的菲姆港有效地建立了一个城邦，这个城邦受到了列宁和墨索里尼的赞赏。事实上，墨索里尼后来将邓邓齐奥描述为法西斯的施洗者约翰。多米尼克，你认为墨索里尼在把邓邓齐奥这位非凡的作家转变为政治领袖的人描述为法西斯的施洗者约翰时，他切中要害了吗？我认为他确实切中了要害，我认为邓邓齐奥是……如果你想找一个典型的例子，看看糟糕的作家往往如何成为你最喜欢的主题之一、尤其是你最喜欢的主题之一
sort of um romantic individualists with an idea of their own greatness. I think D'Annunzio is exhibit A. I think D'Annunzio, as we will discuss in the podcast, he does have this incredible life full of adventure and incident and eroticism and bad behavior and all this sort of stuff. But in his emphasis on the great man and his love of modernity, of speed, his worship, his exaltation of blood and sacrifice and violence, his belief in conquest, his belief that his native country has been mutilated, his hatred of parliamentary democracy. All of these things, and not least the black uniforms.
比如……浪漫的个人主义者，有着自己伟大的理念。我认为邓邓齐奥就是最典型的代表。我认为正如我们将在播客中讨论的那样，邓邓齐奥确实拥有充满冒险、偶发事件、情色、不良行为以及所有这类事情的不可思议的人生。但在他强调伟人、对现代性、速度的热爱，他对血统、牺牲和暴力的崇拜与颂扬，他对征服的信念，他坚信自己的祖国遭到了肢解，他对议会民主制的仇恨。所有这些，尤其是黑衬衫。
I think he looks very much like the first fascist. Well, so we are actually calling this episode The First Fascist. So we're pretty much nailing our colours for the last there. But you know what we need is someone who can perhaps answer that question more conclusively. And we have a wonderful question
我认为他看起来非常像第一个法西斯分子。好吧，所以我们实际上将这一集命名为《第一个法西斯分子》。所以我们基本上在最后亮明了我们的立场。但你知道我们需要的是什么，也许是能更确切地回答那个问题的人。我们有一个绝妙的问题
from Sam the Burgundian Wang, who says very simply, who is he and why have I never heard of him? And I would say that if people in this country, in Britain, have heard of him, it's because they have read the brilliant, brilliant, prize-winning biography of him by Lucy Hughes Hallett, The Pike, Gabriele D'Annunzio, poet, seducer and preacher of war, which I think, Lucy, you're with us, won the Samuel Johnson Prize in 2012 and really put D'Annunzio on the kind of the literary and historical map,
来自勃艮第的萨姆·王（Sam the Burgundian Wang），他非常简单地问道：“他是谁？为什么我从来没听说过他？”我想说的是，如果这个国家（英国）的人听说过他，那是因为他们读了露西·休斯-哈利特（Lucy Hughes Hallett）为他写的极其精彩、屡获殊荣的传记《长枪：加布里埃尔·邓邓齐奥，诗人、诱惑者与战争鼓吹者》（The Pike, Gabriele D'Annunzio, poet, seducer and preacher of war）。露西，我想你也在场，这本书荣获了2012年的塞缪尔·约翰逊奖，并且真正让邓邓齐奥进入了文学和历史的视野，
certainly for readers in the Anglophone world. And Lucy, thank you so much for joining us. And I wonder if I could welcome you to the show by repeating Sam the Burgundian Wang's question, who is he and why has Sam the Burgundian Wang's question, who is he? And why has Sam the Burgundian Wang never heard of him? Well, I repeat my subtitle. He was a poet, a seducer and a preacher of all. He was, in his own opinion, the greatest Italian poet since Dante. And actually, I mean, he was not slow in blowing his own trumpet. But there were a lot of people who agreed with him. And I think maybe I'm one of them. He was a great poet, which is very
至少对于英语世界的读者来说是这样的。露西，非常感谢你加入我们。我想我可以重复勃艮第的萨姆·王的问题来欢迎你来到节目中：他是谁？以及为什么勃艮第的萨姆·王从没听说过他？好吧，我重复我的副标题。他是一位诗人、诱惑者和战争鼓吹者。按他自己的看法，他是自但丁以来最伟大的意大利诗人。事实上，我的意思是，他自我吹嘘起来一点也不含糊。但有很多人同意他的看法。我想也许我也是其中之一。他是一位伟大的诗人，这让许多人感到非常不安，
disturbing to a lot of people who would like to think that great art can only be produced by nice people. And D'Annunzio was not a nice person in all sorts of ways, but he was a brilliant writer. And, you know, it's not just me and him who says it. James Joyce thought that he was the greatest writer of the 19th century after Kipling, interesting choice, and Tolstoy. And then Proust loved him as well, didn't he? Proust loved him. He has a lot in common with Proust. And he spent some time in Paris. And very frustratingly, I couldn't find any occasion when they actually met. But we know that Proust was in the audience when one of Donizio's plays was being put on, sitting
他们宁愿认为伟大的艺术只能由好人创作。而在各种意义上，邓邓齐奥都不是一个好人，但他是一位杰出的作家。而且，你知道，不仅仅是我和他这么说。詹姆斯·乔伊斯认为他是吉卜林之后19世纪最伟大的作家（一个有趣的选角），托尔斯泰也是。然后普鲁斯特也很喜欢他，不是吗？普鲁斯特很喜欢他。他和普鲁斯特有很多共同点。他在巴黎呆过一段时间。非常令人沮丧的是，我找不到他们实际会面的任何记录。但我们知道，当邓邓齐奥的一部戏剧上演时，普鲁斯特就在观众席中，坐在
next to their great mutual friend, Robert de Montesquieu, and coming over a bit faint, as Proust rather tended to do, and retiring to the Caulkland Room. So he didn't get out and about enough to meet D'Anoncier, but they were moving in the same circles. But yes, so he was a poet, much admired. Henry James thought he was terrific as well. And he was a seducer. I mean, he was a real star of the celebrity gossip columns. And he saw the fascists as rather cheap, vulgar, fake versions of himself. Certainly, they took a great deal from him, including an understanding that, you know, politics is all about publicity.
他们伟大的共同朋友罗伯特·德·孟德斯鸠旁边，并且有点晕厥过去——普鲁斯特过去常常这样——然后退到了科尔克兰室。所以他没有四处走动去见邓邓齐奥，但他们身处同一个社交圈。不过是的，他是一位诗人，备受赞赏。亨利·詹姆斯也认为他棒极了。他是个诱惑者。我的意思是，他是名人八卦专栏里真正的明星。他认为法西斯分子只不过是廉价、庸俗、虚假的自己。当然，他们从他那里借鉴了很多东西，包括这样一个认识：政治全在于宣传。
And D'Annunzio was working the press almost from the moment that Italy got a press. When Sam says, why has he never heard of him? Do you think that D'Annunzio's fame, which he was so obsessed by, has to a degree been blotted out by Mussolini and by the emergence of fascism? Well, one of the reasons that Sam hasn't heard of him as a writer is that his novels were so sexually explicit that when they were translated into English, they were so heavily burglarized that they almost make no sense whatsoever because 75% of the action gets left out. So that's kind of maybe a less serious reason. And his poetry doesn't translate very easily. There are translations, but frankly, none of them are much good. You've got to learn
几乎从意大利拥有报纸的那一刻起，邓邓齐奥就一直在迎合媒体。当萨姆问，为什么他从未听说过他？你认为邓邓齐奥曾经如此痴迷的名声，在某种程度上被墨索里尼和法西斯主义的崛起给掩盖了吗？嗯，萨姆没听说过他作为作家的原因之一是，他的小说在性方面的描写非常露骨，以至于当它们被翻译成英文时，被删改得面目全非，几乎毫无意义，因为75%的情节都被删掉了。所以这可能是一个不那么严肃的原因。而且他的诗歌翻译起来并不容易。虽然有译本，但坦率地说，没有一本写得很好。如果你想理解邓邓齐奥作为诗人的天才，你必须去学
Italian if you want to understand the genius of Donizio as a poet. And so as a literary figure, he doesn't travel very easily. But then it's true that his political persona was eclipsed by Mussolini, by the fascists, and by the fact that Mussolini was not keen actually to acknowledge his debt to Donizio. Donizio wrote to Mussolini in the mid-twenties saying, isn't it true that all that is best the substance, the militarism, the extreme nationalism, the elitism, the anti-democratic views, but also the kind of the manner of fascism politics is a performance art. All of that is something that D'Annunzio was onto back in the 1890s, when Mussolini was scarcely thinking about politics. And if he was, he was a socialist. Can we put D'Annunzio Lussi into his original context a bit? So he's born in 1863, two and a half years after the unification of the Kingdom of the two Sicilies and the northern Italian Piedmont kingdom, so basically the creation of the kingdom of Italy.
意大利语。因此，作为文学人物，他并不容易广为人知。不过话虽如此，他的政治形象确实被墨索里尼、法西斯分子以及墨索里尼其实并不热衷于承认他对邓邓齐奥的债务这一事实所黯然失色。二十年代中期，邓邓齐奥写信给墨索里尼说，难道不是吗？法西斯政治的所有最好之处——本质、军国主义、极端民族主义、精英主义、反民主观点，以及法西斯政治的那种方式，都是一种表演艺术。所有这些都是邓邓齐奥在19世纪90年代就已经涉足的东西，当时墨索里尼几乎还没开始考虑政治。如果他当时在想政治，那他也是个社会主义者。露西，我们能把邓邓齐奥放回他原本的背景中吗？所以他出生于1863年，即两西西里王国和意大利北部皮埃蒙特王国统一后两年半，基本上也就是意大利王国的建立。
Do you think he – so he's growing up in the shadow, I suppose, of the Risorgimento and of Garibaldi and so on. Do you think he felt as a young boy – because you say in your book how he's obsessed with glory. I mean, lots of little boys are obsessed with battles and cavalry charges and things, but they don't then become proto-fascists. Do you think he felt that he'd missed out
你认为他——所以他是在复兴运动、加里波第等人的阴影下长大的。你认为他在还是个小男孩的时候——因为你在书中提到他是多么痴迷于荣耀。我的意思是，很多小男孩都痴迷于战斗、骑兵冲锋之类的事情，但他们后来并没有成为准法西斯分子。你认为他觉得自己错过了什么吗？
and that his life was compensating for that a little bit? There may be a bit of that, but I think also he might have felt, he did feel that he was in the right place at the right time. So yes, as you say, 1860, Italy begins to be unified. And then that process is completed in 1870, when the French leave Rome, and Italy becomes a nation state. And Donizio, aged seven, very quickly began to see that he might have a great part in the creation of the new Italy. So there was a kind of catchphrase that
而他的生活在某种程度上弥补了这一点？或许有一点这方面的原因，但我认为他可能也觉得，他确实觉得自己在正确的时间来到了正确的地点。所以，是的，正如你所说，1860年，意大利开始统一。然后这一进程在1870年法国撤出罗马、意大利成为一个民族国家时完成。七岁的邓邓齐奥很快开始看到，他可能会在新意大利的创建中扮演重要角色。所以当时流传着一句话：
was going around at the time. I've tried, but I can't be sure who said it first, but certainly Denuncia was one of the people who said it afterwards, that the Risorgimento made Italy, and the next task was to make Italians. And in order to make Italians, in order to give this great sort of hodgepodge of peoples with very different languages even. I mean, you know, Tuscan was to become the, the Tuscan dialect would become the official Italian. But, you know, people in the Deep South and people in the Far North
我试过了，但我不确定是谁先说的，不过邓邓齐奥肯定是事后说过这话的人之一：复兴运动缔造了意大利，接下来的任务就是塑造意大利人。为了塑造意大利人，为了给这个拥有截然不同语言的大杂烩般的人民（甚至，你知道的，托斯卡纳语将成为……托斯卡纳方言将成为官方意大利语，但你知道，远南部的人和远北部的人）
could barely understand each other. Communications were very poor and slow. There really wasn't much connection and somehow people the people who lived in the Italian peninsula had to be taught to think of themselves as being a part of this new glorious Italy that had just come into being and Donizio saw his opportunity a nation it needs a culture, it needs a poet. And this is part of what he meant when he said he was the greatest poet since Dante. He thought that Dante, in his writing, had a vision of Italy, of a great country called Italy.
几乎互相听不懂。通讯非常糟糕且缓慢。实际上没有太多联系，不知何故，生活在意大利半岛的人们必须被教导把自己视为刚刚诞生的这个新的、光荣的意大利的一部分。邓邓齐奥看到了他的机会：一个国家需要文化，需要一个诗人。这就是他声称自己是自但丁以来最伟大的诗人时部分的意思。他认为但丁在他的写作中对意大利、对一个名为意大利的伟大国家有着宏大的愿景。
And Lucy, he's thinking this when he's at school. Oh, yes, yes. He didn't hang about. And he was thinking this when he's at school. Oh, yes, yes. He didn't hang about. And he was fantastically clever. I mean, when he was 11, he was sent off to a boarding school. And the first Easter that he was there, he wrote a letter to his parents, kind of just for fun, in Spanish, Latin, ancient Greek, Italian, naturally, and English and French. You know, he was already fluent in all those languages. He was frighteningly clever. And he would steal the other boy's lamp oil so that he could stay up all night studying. He had voracious intellectually. He wanted to read everything.
露西，他在上学时就已经这么想了吗？哦，是的，是的。他可没闲着。他在上学时就已经这么想了。哦，是的，是的。他可没闲着。而且他聪明绝顶。我的意思是，他11岁就被送去寄宿学校。在那里的第一个复活节，他写了一封信给父母，纯粹好玩，分别用西班牙语、拉丁语、古希腊语、理所当然的意大利语、英语和法语。你知道，他当时已经能流利使用所有这些语言了。他聪明得吓人。他会偷别的男孩的灯油，好让自己熬夜学习。他有着贪婪的求知欲。他想阅读一切。
And once he'd read absolutely all the literature that was available to him, he thought he could do better. And so, age 16, he published his first volume of verse. It did all right, but he was getting good reviews on the book pages, but that wasn't enough for him. He wanted to be a real super duper front page celebrity. So when he had his second book ready to come out, he was still only just 17 and still at boarding school, he informed a newspaper editor of the tragic death in a riding accident of that brilliant young prodigy, Gabriele D'Annunzio himself. And the editor fell for it, the story ran,
一旦他读完了所有能读到的文学作品，他觉得他自己能写得更好。于是，在16岁时，他出版了他的第一册诗集。它反响不错，他在书评专栏里获得了好评，但这对他来说还不够。他想成为一个真正的超级巨星、头版名人。因此，当他的第二本书准备出版时，他甚至还不到17岁，依然在寄宿学校里，他通知了一位报社编辑，说那位杰出的年轻神童加布里埃尔·邓邓齐奥本人在一次骑马事故中悲惨身亡。那个编辑信以为真，这则新闻被刊登了出来，
was picked up and repeated. And it made him famous. There were long pieces about this brilliant lad, this tragic prodigy. And so when, two weeks later, Donatio knew when to kill the story. He sent a second telegram saying how outraged he was, how deeply distressed. But he had, after long and careful thought, decided that he wasn't going to sue the editor who published it. So he would have been a genius on social media. Oh, yes. I mean, absolutely bossed it. And he was very, I mean, he was very quick to, he went to Rome aged 18 already, author
随后被争相转载。这让他出了名。到处都是关于这位才华横溢的少年、这位悲剧神童的长篇报道。因此，两周后，当邓邓齐奥知道什么时候该收手时，他发了第二封电报，表达了自己的愤怒和深深的悲痛。但他经过长久而深思熟虑后，决定不起诉那个发表该报道的编辑。所以他绝对是社交媒体上的天才。哦，是的。我的意思是，绝对掌控全场。而且他非常——我的意思是，他非常迅速地……他在18岁时就已经来到罗马，
of two acclaimed volumes at first. And he became a hack. I mean, he wrote fashion copy. He went along to parties and wrote the notes about what the Duchess of so-and-so was wearing and so on and so forth. And his sort of highbrow young friends were very shocked. They said, you know, you're prostituting, what are you doing? And he said, I'm speaking to the people. He said, you can write, you can plant an idea in a book, and a few people are going to read it. If you plant it in a popular journal, it's going to flourish.
作为两部广受好评的早期作品的作者，他成了一名写稿匠。我的意思是，他写时尚稿。他参加派对，写一些关于某某公爵夫人穿什么的笔记，诸如此类。他那些眼光高傲的年轻朋友们感到非常震惊。他们说，你知道的，你在出卖自己，你在干什么？他说，我在对人民说话。他说，你可以写作，你可以把一个想法写进书里，只有少数人会读到它。如果你把它种在受欢迎的期刊里，它就会繁荣发展。
It's going to grow. And all of that, Lucy, makes him sound, well, I mean, people make their own minds up, but you could say makes him sound quite an admirable person. But at the same time, he's monstrously egotistical but also there is this um erotomania i mean no one who reads your book could fail i think to draw that conclusion the endless stream of of mistresses and lovers the but his obsession with it the notes that he makes and all this but also there's an element of there's only a couple of times that
它会成长。露西，所有这一切，让他听起来——嗯，人们可以自己下结论，但你可能会说这让他听起来像个相当令人钦佩的人。但与此同时，他有着可怕的利己主义，而且还有一种色情狂热——我想，任何读过你书的人都不可能不得出这个结论：无休止的情妇和情人，他对这件事的痴迷，他做的笔记以及所有这些。但其中还有一个成分——虽然只有几次提到——他吹奸污农家女或强迫自己对待工人阶级女性。你不知道这是不是一种愿望的实现、某种幻想，还是它真的发生了。所以所有这些究竟是怎么回事？
it comes up of him boasting of having raped peasant girls or having forced himself on working class women. And you don't know whether this is wish fulfillment, a kind of fantasy, or whether it really happened. So what's going on with all that sort of stuff? Well, I think the first thing to say is he behaved deplorably to women. There's absolutely no way to defend it. As you say, there are only a few mentions in the notebooks about the way he would force himself on or rape working class women, servants or women he came across. I don't think he did that very often. I think that was when he was a boy. And by the time he was kind of 17, 18, he was a star. And he was very interested, actually, in the way that he could get women
嗯，我想首先要说的是，他对女性的行为极其恶劣。绝对没有任何方式可以为之辩护。正如你所说，在他的笔记本中只有几次提到他如何强迫自己对待或强奸工人阶级女性、女仆或他遇到的女性。我不认为他经常这样做。我想那是他还是个男孩的时候。等到他十七、八岁时，他已经是个明星了。而且他实际上对如何追求女性非常感兴趣，
because he wasn't good looking. He was small. He went bald very early. He had lovely sort of dark curls in his teens and very early 20s. But nothing wrong with being bald, by the way. Yeah, I'm glad you say that. But, you know, he really wasn't a beauty. One of his many, many mistresses said that he was the only person she'd ever met who had teeth in three different colours.
因为他长得并不好看。他个子矮。他秃顶得很早。他在十几岁和二十岁出头时有着一头可爱深色的卷发……顺便说一句，秃头没什么不好的。是的，我很高兴你这么说。但是，你知道，他真的算不上是个美人。他的众多情妇之一曾说过，他是她见过的唯一一个牙齿有三种不同颜色的人：
White, yellow and black. Very British. colours white yellow and black very british but he and he had um he had an affair with the most famous um actress of her day in italy eleanor aduse yes and actually the majority of his his known lovers um apart from you know the odd people he bedded in the afternoon and never saw again kind of thing. And there were many of those. And we just noticed them down in his notebooks without even giving names. But the lovers that stayed around
白色、黄色和黑色。非常英国。颜色有白色、黄色和黑色，非常英国。但他——他曾与意大利当时最著名的女演员埃莱奥诺拉·杜塞（Eleonora Duse）有过一段情。是的，事实上，他已知的情人中大部分——除了你在下午随便睡了之后再也没见过的那种人。有很多人是这样的。我们在笔记本上把他们记下来，甚至都不写名字。但那些留下来、
and who were important to him were nearly all women either of great talent or they were very grand. He liked women he could respect, whether first of snobbish social reasons or because he did admire their talent. And he and Dusser were partners. She'd been playing the Lady of the Camellias over and over and over and over again.
对他很重要的情人几乎都是要么才华横溢、要么出身高贵的女性。他喜欢他能尊重的女性，无论是出于势利社交的原因，还是因为他确实钦佩她们的才华。他和杜塞是合作伙伴。她曾一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地扮演《茶花女》。
She was looking for new material. And de Monceau wrote plays for her. And she was an international celebrity long before he was. So by taking his works on tour around the world, and she went to Russia, she went to America, she came to England, et cetera, she greatly expanded his reach. And she was the boss.
她在寻找新素材。邓邓齐奥为她写剧本。而且早在邓邓齐奥之前，她就已经是一位国际名流了。因此，通过带着他的作品在世界各地巡演——她去过俄罗斯、去过美国、来过英国等等——她极大地扩展了邓邓齐奥的影响力。而且她是老板。
You know, she wasn't just the actress. She was the producer of these shows that she took around the world. So she was a considerable person in her own right. I hesitate to say that D'Avanzio respected women because he treated them abominably. But he liked them to be his intellectual equals. He liked to be able to talk to them. And Lucy, on the subject of his intellectual life, one of the things that's really striking reading your book is how alert he is to all the kind of big intellectual trends
你知道，她不仅仅是演员。她还是她带到世界各地这些演出的制作人。所以她本身就是一个相当了不起的人物。我不敢说邓邓齐奥尊重女性，因为他对她们态度恶劣。但他喜欢她们成为他在知识上的平等对手。他喜欢能够与她们对话。露西，谈到他的精神生活时，读你的书时一个非常惊人的发现是，他对20世纪将要席卷而来的所有重大知识潮流保持着多么敏锐的警觉，你知道，当这些潮流还不太为人所知的时候。所以他很早就对尼采的著作保持警觉；他对所有将在《春之祭》中爆发的东西保持警觉，你知道，比如异教仪式和所有此类事情；
that will roll over the 20th century, you know, when they're just very kind of not widely known. So he's very alert to the writings of Nietzsche early on. He is alert to all the kind of stuff that will explode with the rites of spring kind of you know pagan ritual and all that kind of thing um and he's very very into modernity so he's he's writing kind of odes to torpedoes and things like that he does that when he's a teenager doesn't he i think the torpedo ode very early on yes is that one of the things that i mean that really distinguishes him is that he has a kind of incredibly advanced antennae for things that are going to be big in the 20th
而且他非常非常痴迷于现代性——所以他为鱼雷之类的事情写颂歌，他在十几岁的时候就这么做了，不是吗？我想鱼雷颂歌很早就有了，对吗？这就是……这真的是真正让他与众不同的地方之一吗？他对20世纪将大行其道的事物有着极其敏锐的触角？绝对是的。是的，你形容得太完美了。这就是为什么我的书名叫《长枪》（The Pike），因为我不是个渔夫，但显然长枪鱼潜伏在浅水区。
century? Absolutely. Yes, you put it perfectly. And that's why my book is called The Pike because I'm not a fisher person, but apparently what pike do is they lurk in the shallows. And just when something comes drifting past on the current, they snap. And D'Onozio was great at that. He could pick up a trend. I mean, it might be a hairstyle, or it might be an intellectual trend, long before anyone around him had really kind of picked up on it. And so, yes, certainly, I mean, he was a futurist, you know, when Marinetti was still in the nursery. And he loved motorcars, telephones, aeroplanes. He became an aviator.
就在有什么东西随水流漂过时，它们猛地咬住。邓邓齐奥在这方面非常厉害。他能捕捉到一种潮流。我的意思是，可能是一个发型，也可能是一种思想潮流，早在周围任何人真正察觉之前。所以，是的，当然，我的意思是，当马里内蒂还在托儿所时，他就是一个未来主义者。他热爱汽车、电话、飞机。他成了一名飞行员。
And yes, there's the early ode to the torpedo. He was very excited by modern weaponry and by big ships and later by airplanes. And he was always just a few steps ahead of everybody else. He had fantastic capacity to absorb ideas. And I say absorb because he seemed to be able to suck a book dry without actually reading it. He was coming up with Nietzschean ideas and crediting Nietzsche long before he'd actually got a copy of any of Nietzsche's works in his hands because they weren't translated into Italian for a long time. He was reading Nietzsche in French.
是的，早期还有对鱼雷的颂歌。他对现代武器、大船以及后来的飞机感到非常兴奋。他总是比其他人领先几步。他有着吸收思想的奇妙能力。我说“吸收”，是因为他似乎能够在不真正阅读的情况下把一本书吸干。早在他的手中拿到任何尼采作品的副本之前，他就已经提出了尼采式的思想并归功于尼采，因为尼采的作品很长时间内没有被翻译成意大利语。他在用法语读尼采。
He had a kind of secretary come personal shopper come Leparello who was his sort of his aid his aid to camp throughout a lot of his life tom antongini who later wrote a book about him um who described donanzio kind of flicking through a book in let us say five minutes and then talking about it for over an hour without a moment's pause. We could get him on this podcast, Tom. But he's also very good, isn't he, Lucy? Well, not very good. That's completely the wrong phrase. But he's very, it's not just intellectual trends,
他有一个类似秘书兼私人采购员兼莱波雷洛（Leparel）的人物，在他人生的很大一部分时间里担任他的助手、副官——托马索·安托吉尼（Tom Antongini），他后来写了一本关于他的书——描述了邓邓齐奥如何用，比方说五分钟的时间翻阅一本书，然后毫无停顿地谈论它一个多小时。我们可以请他上这个播客，托马索。但他也很厉害，不是吗，露西？嗯，不只是厉害。这完全用错词了。但他非常——不仅仅是思想潮流，
it's also political trends. Because quite early on, he is in that sort of, I don't know, 40-year period where Italy is trying to find itself. They have something like 35 administrations in 40 years, don't they? It's a real kind of parliamentary shambles, the Italian state after it's been unified. He is calling it foul. He's saying parliamentary democracy is vulgar, it's depraved, the parliament is a sewer, all of these themes that we're very familiar with from the 1920s and 1930s that are kind of proto-fascistic. And do you think that in that respect, is he reflecting a wider, you know, a general Italian context? Or is that something in him?
还有政治潮流。因为很早以前，他就处在那段大概40年的时期里，当时意大利正试图寻找自我。在40年里他们大概有35届政府，不是吗？意大利国家在统一后确实是一团议会混乱。他在抨击这种现象。他说议会民主是庸俗的、堕落的、议会是个下水道，所有这些我们在20世纪20年代和30年代非常熟悉、带有准法西斯色彩的主题。你认为在这方面，他是在反映更广泛的、普遍的意大利背景吗？还是他自身特质的一部分？
Because he also obviously has this kind of very romantic or post-romantic worship of the great man, which runs counter to kind of parliamentary democracy and the-romantic worship of the great man, which runs counter to kind of parliamentary democracy and the kind of pluralism of the modern democratic age. Absolutely, yes. And he was an elitist, not just in the rather vague way the word is often used nowadays, but because he really believed there were some people who were better than others,
因为他显然也对伟大人物有着这种非常浪漫或后浪漫主义的崇拜，这与议会民主制以及现代民主时代的多元主义背道而驰。绝对是的。而且他是一个精英主义者，不仅仅是以现在这个词经常被使用的那种比较含糊的方式，而是因为他真的相信有些人的确比其他人优秀，
and those were the people who should be ruling. And they wouldn't necessarily be aristocrats. He had very hard words to say about the spineless offspring of exhausted aristocracies. I mean, he read Darwin or absorbed Darwin's ideas in the way that he did. And he drew the same sort of conclusions from Darwin that Nietzsche was to do, but separately, before he came across Nietzsche. If you think about evolution, it doesn't happen uniformly, he thought. In every generation, there will be some people who have evolved further than others. And he saw himself in that light. Oh, you bet. Yes, yes, yes. So the Superman. He was you bet. Yes, yes, yes. So the superman.
而那些人应该进行统治。他们不一定非得是贵族。对于那些筋疲力尽的贵族阶层中脊梁骨软弱的后代，他发表了非常严厉的言论。我的意思是，他阅读达尔文或以他自己的方式吸收了达尔文的思想。他从达尔文身上得出了与尼采相同的结论，但那是独立得出的，在他接触到尼采之前。如果你考虑进化，它不会均一地发生，他认为。在每一代人中，总会有些人比其他人进化得更远。他以这种眼光看待自己。哦，那是肯定的。是的，是的，是的。所以超人。他就是
He was the superman. He definitely was. And the superman should rule. And so he did briefly sit in parliament. He was in the 1890s. The seat for his birthplace, Pescara e Neobruti, came up and it was offered to him. And because he never liked to say no to anything, he thought he'd give it a go.
超人。他绝对是的。而且超人应该统治。因此，他曾短暂地坐在议会里。那是在19世纪90年代。他的出生地佩斯卡拉和新布鲁蒂的席位空缺了，并提供给了他。由于他从不喜欢对任何事情说不，他觉得自己不妨一试。
But already he'd sort of gone into print by then to describe the Chamber of Deputies as a mephitic sewer, the stable in which the filthy beast... So he's a kind of populist, as we now describe him. But he's not a populist if he's an elitist. Well, he's an elitist populist. It's so confusing. He didn't like the people much,
但当时他已经通过出版物将众议院描述为“毒气腾腾的下水道，装着肮脏野兽的马厩……”所以他是一种我们现在所说的民粹主义者。但如果他是精英主义者，他就不是民粹主义者。嗯，他是一个精英主义的民粹主义者。这太令人困惑了。他其实不太喜欢人民，
but he did want them to buy his books. He believed in this elite, which was not socially determined. It was a grouping of the great. And quite how you knew whether you were part of this group is a little unclear. D'Annunzio was absolutely clear that he was one of the saved, one of the elite.
但他确实希望他们买他的书。他信仰这个并非由社会阶层决定的精英阶层。这是一个伟大之人的集团。至于你如何知道自己是否属于这个集团，其实有点含糊不清。邓邓齐奥绝对清楚自己是被拯救者之一、是精英之一。
But when he joined Parliament, he didn't sit in the House very often, which was normal. Over half the deputies never took their seats at that point, which was one of the problems with Italian democracy. But after a bit, he sat on the right wing with the kind of the nationalists, militarists, monarchists. And then after a bit, he crossed the house and went and sat with the socialists. Not because he in any way approved of socialism, but because he thought they had a bit of, you know, a
但当他加入议会时，他并不经常坐在议席上，这很正常。当时有一半以上的议员从未就座，这也是当时意大利民主的问题之一。但过了一会儿，他坐在右翼，和民族主义者、军国主义者、保皇党人坐在一起。然后过了一会儿，他跨过议会大厅，去和社会主义者坐在一起。不是因为他在任何意义上赞同社会主义，而是因为他认为他们身上有一点生命力。
bit of life to them. And what he was looking for always, and actually this is also, I think, true of a lot of Mussolini's fascism. It's not about the doctrine. It's about the energy. Yeah, the swagger, the show, the the dazzle and splendor yeah the spectacle and what's that there's that virility element to yes to it isn't there that was obviously i mean it's so interesting how that's there so early on with him i mean he's obsessed with his own manliness
他一直在寻找的，事实上这也是我认为墨索里尼的法西斯主义的许多特点——这与教义无关。这关乎活力。是的，大摇大摆、做派、炫耀与辉煌，还有奇观，以及其中存在的男子气概元素。对，是的，难道不是吗？显然——我的意思是，这如此有趣，它在他身上这么早就存在了。我的意思是，他痴迷于自己的男子汉气概，
isn't he and again was that something do you think that's rooted in his own psychology or do you think it's generally it's in the air in late 19th century Italy? I think it's very much in the air. He was an extreme version of it in a way that's quite paradoxical, given that he loved flower arranging and pretty clothes. He's very stylish, isn't he? All the photos, he always looks tremendously cool. Yes, yes.
不是吗？同样，你认为这根植于他自己的心理，还是它普遍存在于19世纪末的意大利空气中？我认为它很大程度上弥漫在空气中。他是一个极端的版本，以一种相当矛盾的方式——鉴于他热爱插花和漂亮的衣服。他非常有品位，不是吗？所有的照片里，他看起来总是酷毙了。是的，是的。
There was a time when he went off on a on a boat trip a friend of his had a yacht and they set off around the adriatic denuncio took on board 40 white linen suits to the group's care of his his friends who were just thinking they were going to be you know chilling on deck not wearing very much at all so he'd wear the right shoes on on a yacht he would do tom he would do very important but but lucy so we've conveyed the sense of a man who is convinced of his own greatness and of his own destiny but it would be fair to say wouldn't it that say by his late 20s he's still essentially just a literary figure would that be would that be reasonable to say and then in 1910 he gets so heavily into debt that he actually has to run away to Paris. Absolutely, yes. I mean, so he really in his 30s, he begins to take an active interest in politics,
曾经有一次，他去进行了一次划船旅行——他的一个朋友有一艘游艇，他们出发环游亚得里亚海。邓邓齐奥在船上带了40套白色的亚麻西装，而他的朋友们原本以为他们只是要在甲板上放松一下，不需要穿太多的衣服。所以他会在游艇上穿合适的鞋子。托马索会这么做的，确实非常重要。但是，露西，所以我们传达了一种这样的印象：这是一个坚信自己伟大和自己命运的人。但这样说公平吗——比方说，到他快三十岁时，他基本上依然只是一位文学人物？这样说合理吗？然后到了1910年，他负债累累，以至于不得不逃往巴黎。绝对是的。我的意思是，他在三十多岁时开始积极参与政治，
at which point I have to say that the quality of his literary output deteriorates. It becomes more and more polemical, his poetry becomes more ranting, and he loses the sort of the delicacy of his earlier writings. But he's, you say, just a literary type, and all the hackles of the literary types listening to this podcast are rising because... We hope there are no such people listening to this podcast. But anyway, he thought that too. There came a point in his life when he thought that to be just a scribbler wasn't enough. He wanted to set nations ablaze. He used the word holocaust a lot. It didn't have the connotations that it now has. He was taking it from his reading of Flaubert's Salambo, in which there is a holocaust, a human sacrifice, and a holocaust is a kind of sacrifice
在这个节点上，我不得不说，他文学作品的质量恶化了。它变得越来越好辩，他的诗歌变得更加谩骂，他失去了早期作品的那种细腻。但你刚刚说“只是一位文学类型”，所有听到这个播客的文学类型人士的汗毛都竖起来了……我们希望没有这样的人在听这个播客。但无论如何，他也这么想。在他的人生中曾有一个时刻，他认为仅仅做一个涂鸦者是不够的。他想要点燃国家。他经常使用“大屠杀”（holocaust）这个词。它当时没有现在那样的含义。他是从阅读福楼拜的《萨朗波》（Salammbô）中借用的这个词，其中有一场大屠杀、一种活人祭祀，而“holocaust”是一种祭品被完全吞噬的祭祀。总之，邓邓齐奥想要点燃一场大屠杀、一处熊熊烈火，让火星飞溅到整个意大利和整个欧洲，鼓励人民起义，摆脱他们那些无聊、软弱、平庸、男子气概不足的自由派统治者，变得更加嗜血、更具侵略性、更加民族主义。因此，当1914年他在巴黎、战争爆发时，他对此感到非常兴奋。他去了前线，不是吗，去看看发生了什么？是的，他去了。他在巴黎，而且他很兴奋，因为他一直在等待这场战争。他相信——最令人震惊的是，
in which the sacrificial victim is entirely consumed. Anyway, D'Arnozio wanted to light a great holocaust, a great fire from which the sparks would fly all over Italy and all over Europe and encourage the people to rise up, get rid of their boring, feeble, mediocre, insufficiently virile, liberal rulers, and become much more bloodthirsty, more aggressive, and more nationalist. And so when, in 1914, he's in Paris, war breaks out, he's very excited by this. And he goes to the front, doesn't he, to kind of see what's going on? Yes, he does. And he's in Paris and he's sort of excited because he's been waiting for this war. He believes, and the most shocking thing
他并不孤单。有许多意大利民族主义者也这样认为，意大利需要一场战争。敌人是谁或战争的原因可能是什么并不重要。关键在于意大利是一个新国家，到目前为止只存在了30年、40年。它还没有经历过他所说的“血的洗礼”。因此他想，太棒了，就是这样。这是我们必须加入并证明我们是伟大人民的地方。他住在法国。他在错误的地方。这让他感到担忧。但他开始在意大利和法国的报纸上撰写充满好战情绪的社论和特稿，呼吁意大利政府加入他们的拉丁兄弟法国一方。
about this is that he's not alone. There are a lot of Italian nationalists who also believe it, that what Italy needs is a war. And it doesn't really matter who the enemy is or what the cause of war might be. The point is that Italy is a new nation, only been around for 30 years, 40 years by now. It hasn't yet had what he called the baptism of blood. And so he thinks, great, this is it. This is where we must join and we must show that we are great people. He's living in France. He's in the wrong place. And that's a worry to him. But he starts writing really bellicose editorials, features for newspapers, both in Italy and in France, calling on the Italian government to get involved on the side of their Latin brothers, the French.
他对英国人或俄国人一点兴趣都没有，但法国人和意大利人应该团结起来，因为他们是古代和中世纪伟大文明的继承者。不过，是的，当他还在法国时他就去了前线。他正在发展一种关于大地的、极其可怕的神话，把大地视为一个想要吮吸自己儿子鲜血的母亲。所以这是一种吸血鬼般的、母性的吸血鬼。这个可怜的年轻士兵在战壕里被杀了。他们的鲜血正在渗入战壕，渗入土地。这一切都很骇人，但他觉得非常兴奋。
He's not at all interested in the British or the Russians, but the French and the Italians should band together because they are the kind of the heirs to the great civilizations of ancient Rome and medieval Italy. But yes, he goes to the front while he's still in France. He's developing a kind of a really appalling kind of mythology of the earth as a mother who wants to suck down the blood of her sons. So a kind of vampire, maternal vampire. This wretched young soldier has been killed in the trenches. Their blood is seeping into the trenches, into the land. It's all horrifying, but he finds it very exciting.
但随后在1915年5月，他回到了意大利。意大利人表面上依然置身事外。他想回去。他回到了意大利，而此时他一直在写的那些极具好战色彩的特稿已经让他成为了民族主义、军国主义右翼的大英雄。当他穿过意大利边境时，他的火车一次又一次被拦截，接着他开始了自己的一系列伟大演讲。
But then he goes back to Italy in May 1915. The Italians are still, ostensibly anyway, staying out of the war. And he wants to go back. He returns to Italy, by which time these very bellicose features he's been writing have made him a great hero of the kind of nationalist, militarist right. And his train is stopped repeatedly as he comes across the Italian frontier, and then he embarks on his great series of speeches.
我们应该在这里停下来插播一些资本主义广告，我们一向喜欢这么做。我不知道邓邓齐奥会对这个作何感想。他真的很喜欢宣传，所以他大概会很喜欢。然后我们会回来，托马索。是的。
We should take a break here for some capitalist advertising, which we always like to do. I don't know what Derncier would make of that. He really liked publicity, so he'd probably love it. And then we'll come back, Tom. Yes.
我们将深入探讨第一次世界大战。以及战后余波。以及余波，没错。最非凡、最非凡的故事。所以精彩还在后头。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And we'll get into the Great War. And the aftermath. And the aftermath, exactly. The most extraordinary, most extraordinary story. So the best is yet to come. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们共同主持《闲人 娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家播客和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《闲人 懂史》。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
“饥渴慕义的青年是有福的，因为他们必得饱足。怜恤人的人是有福的，因为他们将受邀去止住奔涌的壮丽鲜血，包扎美妙的伤口。拥有最多的人是有福的，因为他们能付出最多、敢作敢当最多。凯旋归来的人是有福的，因为他们将看到罗马的新面孔。”这是对登山宝宣的恶搞。恶搞这个词不太准确，这是对登山宝宣的一种扭曲的重新演绎——恶搞不对，是对登山宝宣的一种扭曲重新演绎，由加布里埃尔·邓邓齐奥在他返回——我想是热那亚时发表的，露西，当时他踏上了你刚才谈到的返回意大利的伟大火车之旅。这——我的意思是，你的书里有很多关于邓邓齐奥行为的骇人听闻的事情。但在我看来，这是最糟糕的事情之一：他回到意大利，回到一个在加入第一次世界大战边缘颤抖的国家。他发表了这些演讲，对任何一个神智正常的人来说，我都得说，
Blessed are the young who hunger and thirst for glory, for they shall be satisfied. Blessed are the merciful, for they shall be called upon to staunch a splendid flow of blood and dress a wonderful wound. Blessed are they that have most, because they can give most, dare most. Blessed are they who return with victories, for they shall see the new face of Rome. So that's a parody of the Sermon on the Mount. A parody is the wrong word, a sort of twisted reworking of the Sermon on the Mount, a parody is the wrong word, a sort of twisted reworking of the Sermon of the Mount delivered by Gabriele D'Annunzio on his return, I think, to Genoa, Lucy, when he made this great train journey that you were talking about back into Italy. And this is, I mean, there's lots of horrific things in your book about D'Annunzio's behavior. But to me, this is one of the worst, that he returns to Italy, to a country that's sort of trembling on the brink of entering the Great War. And he delivers these speeches that, to any sane reader, I would say,
它们完全令人作呕，满嘴都是年轻人流血牺牲，血流成河，那将是美妙的。而且，你知道，当他高喊“我们将列出反对战争的人的名单并剥夺他们的公民权”时，人们狂热地欢迎他，人群欢呼雀跃，甚至有人喜极而泣。这到底是怎么回事？是邓邓齐奥的名人效应，还是他在触动某种东西？基本上，你认为在1915年有很多人像他一样思考吗？绝对是的。这就是——正如你所说，关于邓邓齐奥，有太多令人震惊的地方。
are utterly repulsive, all about young men sacrificing, you know, pools of blood will, there'll be rivers of blood will flow, it'll be wonderful. And, you know, he is received with rapture by this tremendous crowds when he's shouting, you know, we'll make lists of people who oppose the war and prescribe them. People are sort of weeping for joy and stuff. I mean, what's going on? Is it Donizio's celebrity that's, or is he tapping something? Basically, there are lots of people that think like him, do you think, in 1915? Absolutely. And that's really, I mean, as you say, there are lots of people that think like him, do you think, in 1915? Absolutely. And that's really, I mean, as you say, there's so much that's appalling about D'Annunzio.
而这也许是最令人震惊的事情，那就是他如此这般——血的洗礼、净化之血、赋能之血，为了使一个国家伟大而必须倾泻的鲜血——这是我们在法国、在意大利、在这个国家甚至也能找到的东西。邓邓齐奥曾写过关于妥协的诗，相比于战场的闪光与荣耀，平民的生活是多么苍白。所以这可以追溯到19世纪。当我们来到第一次世界大战爆发前夕时，就好像普通的平民生活连同它所有的妥协、商业考量、肮脏、卑微一样，而战争提供了一种在某种程度上更纯粹的体验。而且它很可能是致命的这一事实也让人兴奋。这很让人兴奋。人们喜欢思考危险。所以，露西，这里有一个来自科尔的托姆的问题……
And this is perhaps the most appalling thing, is that he was so a kind of, you know, the baptism of blood, the blood that purifies, the blood that energizes, blood that is, has to be poured out in order to make a nation great, is something that, you know, we find, you know, in France, and certainly in Italy, in this country as well, even, you know, Daryl Tennyson was writing poems about the compromised, how pale civilian life was compared with the kind of the glitter and the glory of the battlefields. And so that goes back into the 19th century. And by the time we get to just before the outbreak of the First World War, it's as though ordinary civilian life with all its compromises, its commercial considerations, it's grubby, it's ignoble, and war offers a level of experience which is somehow purer. And the fact that it's also likely to be lethal is exciting. It's exciting. People like thinking about danger. So Lucy, there's a question from Tom at Coal,
而这或许是最令人震惊的事情，那就是他非常符合某种——你知道的——血洗的概念，净化之血，赋予活力的之血，为了使一个国家伟大而必须倾注的鲜血，这种思想我们在法国、当然还有意大利以及我们这个国家都能找到，甚至，你知道的，丁尼生曾写过关于妥协的诗篇，相比于战场上那种闪耀与荣耀，平民生活是多么苍白。所以这可以追溯到19世纪。而当时间来到第一次世界大战爆发前夕时，就好像平民的日常生活连同它所有的妥协、商业考量一样，是肮脏的、卑劣的，而战争提供了一种在某种程度上更纯粹的体验。而且它可能致命这一事实本身也是令人兴奋的。这太刺激了。人们喜欢思考危险。所以，露西，这里有一个来自科尔的汤姆的问题，
who asks how much influence did D'Annunzio have in bringing Italy into the First World War? So how influential was he in what ultimately happens, namely Italy entering on the side of the Allies? Well, disappointingly for D'Annunzio, the answer is much, much less than it appeared. Because actually, the Italians were negotiating throughout the first months of the war from September 1914 through to May 1915. They were negotiating with both sides. They were officially part of a triple alliance with Austria and Germany, which meant that they couldn't, without breaking that alliance treaty, enter the war against Austria and Germany. But actually, most of Italians hated the Austrians in particular, because the Austro-Hungarian Empire had dominated Italy for many centuries. It was mainly they who were being kicked out during the Risorgimento. They were seen as the hereditary enemy. The Italians would have been reluctant to go into the war on that side. But there was no obvious advantage for the Italians going into
谁会问邓农齐奥在促使意大利加入第一次世界大战方面发挥了多大影响？那么他在最终发生的事情，即意大利加入盟军一方的过程中到底有多大影响力？好吧，让邓农齐奥感到失望的是，答案比表面上看起来要小得多、少得多。因为事实上，意大利人在一战头几个月里（从1914年9月到1915年5月）一直在进行谈判。他们当时在与双方进行谈判。他们官方上是奥地利和德国的三国同盟成员，这意味着如果不撕毁那个同盟条约，他们就不能加入反对奥地利和德国的战争。但实际上，大多数意大利人格外痛恨奥地利人，因为奥匈帝国曾统治意大利数个世纪。在复兴运动中被赶走的主要是他们。他们被视为世仇。意大利人本很不情愿站在那一边参战。但意大利人加入战争并没有带来显而易见的好处
war on the side of the Allies. But deals were being cut very secretly. And there was a Treaty of London, which had been secretly agreed before Donizio got off his train, that French and British were offering Italy territory along the Dalmatian coast. And that would be their reward if they came in on the side of the allies of the French and British. And that treaty had actually been signed before Donizio came back. He didn't know that, and nor did anybody else. It was being kept very, very secret. And the Prime Minister was going to have to get it through Parliament, through the Chamber of Deputies, which was going to be hard because there were a lot of anti, the anti-war party was very strong.
加入盟军一方的战争。但当时正在非常秘密地达成一些交易。而且在多尼齐奥下火车之前，双方已经秘密达成了一项《伦敦条约》，法英两国向意大利提供达尔马提亚海岸沿线的领土。如果意大利加入法英盟军一方，这就是他们的奖赏。事实上，在多尼齐奥回来之前，该条约就已经签署了。他不知道这一点，其他人也不知道。这被保守得非常非常秘密。而且首相必须让它在议会、在众议院通过，这将会很艰难，因为有很多人反对，反战党非常强大。
It was led by Giulietti, who was five times prime minister, terrific, charismatic, grand old man of Italian politics. So what was badly needed by the Italian government at that time was someone to sway public opinion and to kind of put the frighteners on the anti-war party until they were prepared to vote this treaty through. And that's what Donizio did. He didn't realize that that was all he was doing. He thought that he was, when he was standing on the Capitol or on the stage of the Opera House or at Quarto, he was calling on the government to stop being so lily-livered and, you know,
它由吉利蒂领导，他曾五次担任首相，是意大利政坛一位了不起的、具有个人魅力的伟大老人。因此，当时意大利政府迫切需要的是有人来左右公众舆论，并对反战党起到某种威慑作用，直到他们准备好投票通过这项条约。这就是多尼齐奥所做的事。他并没有意识到这正是他所做的全部。他认为，当他站在卡皮托利奥山上、或歌剧院的舞台上、或夸尔托时，他是在呼吁政府不要那么软弱无能，你知道的，
brace up and be proper men and declare war. But in fact, secretly, they'd already agreed to do so. He sees himself as a kind of Nietzschean superhero bending history to his will in that kind of scale so he's finally measuring up to his own sense of what his role in history should be in his opinion absolutely no it I think it was probably the most exciting week of his life that week in May when he was giving speeches two or three speeches a day thousands of people roaring carrying him away from the podium it was extraordinary that he didn't get trampled by the crowd. He was a huge public hero to some people, obviously detested by others. And he was inciting the people of Rome to become a lynch mob. And he was actually telling them, go out, track down those deputies who you know are going to vote against intervention in the war,
振作起来，做真正的男子汉并宣战。但事实上，他们私下里已经同意这样做了。他把自己看作某种尼采式的超级英雄，以那种规模将历史扭曲按自己的意志行事，所以他终于符合了他自认为在历史中应扮演的角色的看法，绝对是的，不，我认为这可能是他一生中最激动人心的一周，五月的那个星期，他每天发表两三次演讲，成千上万的人咆哮着，把他从讲台上抬下来，没有被人群踩踏真是奇迹。对某些人来说，他是巨大的公众英雄，当然也遭到其他人的厌恶。他在煽动罗马人民成为私刑暴徒。他实际上在对他们说，走出去，找出那些你们知道将投票反对介入战争的议员，
do what you like with them. He said, if it is a crime to incite a crowd to murder, I am guilty of that crime. He really was. He was completely shamelessly going way beyond proper behavior, way beyond legality. He was calling for violence, even while he was doing that. In the evenings, he would go for lovely walks in the forum and write poems about the fireflies. The two sides of him, this ranting, bloodthirsty demagogue and the very sensitive erudite poet coexist in a way I simply can't explain. And then Italy does enter the war. And Italy's experience of the war is probably, well, certainly as bad as anybody's. So it's, you know, hundreds of thousands of people are thrown into this kind of charnel house of the caste,
对他们随心所欲吧。他说，如果煽动人群谋杀是一种罪行，我犯了那种罪行。他确实如此。他完全无耻地远远超出了正常行为，远远超出了合法性。他在呼吁暴力，甚至在他这样做的时候。到了傍晚，他在广场上散着美好的步，写着关于萤火虫的诗。他的两面性，这个狂暴、嗜血的煽动者与那个非常敏感、博学的诗人以一种我根本无法解释的方式共存。然后意大利确实加入了战争。意大利对战争的经历可能，嗯，绝对和任何人的一样糟糕。所以你知道，成千上万的人被抛进卡斯特这种类似屠宰场的境地，
I guess is the border between Italy and Slovenia, isn't it, where they're fighting the Austrians. It's pointless. It's basically all for nothing. The condition's absolutely horrendous, arguably more horrendous even than the Western Front. They're kind of blowing the tops off mountains, aren't they? Yeah, and people are being killed by sort of bits of rock
我猜那是意大利和斯洛文尼亚之间的边界，不是吗？他们在那里与奥地利人作战。这是毫无意义的。基本上一切都是徒劳的。条件绝对惨烈，可以说甚至比西线还要惨烈。他们有点把山顶给炸飞了，不是吗？是的，人们被某种飞行了一英里然后砸到他们后脑勺上的碎岩块所杀死，这就是他们的结局。你知道，这简直太可怕了。但我想值得赞许邓农齐奥的是，我是说，我讨厌赞许邓农齐奥任何事，因为我认为他太可恶了。但他确实一次又一次地拿自己的生命冒险，不是吗？我是说，特别是通过这些——因为他如此着迷于现代性，他乘坐这些开创性的飞机上天，并失去了右眼视力。是这样吗？
that are flying for a mile before hitting them on the back of the head, and that's the end of them. You know, it's just horrific. But I suppose to D'Annunzio's credit, I mean, I hate to give D'Annunzio credit for anything because I think he's so loathsome. But he does risk his own life, doesn't he, time and again? I mean, particularly with these – because he's so fascinated by modernity, he goes up in these pioneering flights and he loses the sight of his right eye. Is that right?
他基本上差点失明。好吧，他确实失明了一段时间，不是吗？是的，他是。是的，他毫无疑问非常勇敢。而且我认为他还容易出现极度抑郁的发作，其中一次发作发生在他看到战争即将结束的战争最后几周里。他真的、真的不想生活在一个战后的世界里。
And he basically is nearly blinded. Well, he is blinded for a while, isn't he? Yes, he is. Yes, he was unquestionably very brave. And I think that he was also prone to bouts of extreme depression, one of which overtook him in the sort of last weeks of the war when he saw it was about to end. And he really, really did not want to live in a post-war world.
你知道，战争的兴奋感、肾上腺素、他从危险中获得的某种冲动，而且他我想已经对它上瘾了，就像许多参战的人一样。他多次写道，他希望自己被杀，我想他是认真的。但是是的，他的飞行太棒了。他非常勇敢。
You know, the excitement of the war, the adrenaline, the kind of rush he got from danger was, and he'd become, I suppose, addicted to it, as a lot of fighting people do. And he wrote repeatedly that he wished he'd been killed, and I think he meant it. But yes, his flying was amazing. He was very brave.
他真的没有理由在战争中服任何现役。到这时他已经五十多岁了。但他坚持要这样做，这与最高指挥官的意愿相悖，指挥官们认为虽然只要他活着，他对宣传会非常有用，但如果他被杀，那就会是个问题。但他表示，不，不，必须允许他，嗯，做他想做的事。他坐潜艇下水，他乘巡洋舰出海参加战役，然后他成为了一名飞行员。他于1910年在布雷西亚航空展上首次飞行，当时意大利唯一能离开地面的飞行机器，只能离地一米高。在随后的四年里，你知道，技术有了突飞猛进的发展。所以有了战斗机。多尼齐奥从未学会驾驶自己的飞机，但他会
There was really no reason for him to take any kind of active service in the war. He was into his 50s by now. But he insisted, rather against the wishes of the high command, who saw that although he could be very useful for propaganda as long as he stayed alive, if he got killed, that was going to be a problem. But he said, no, no, he must be allowed to um to do whatever he wanted and he went down in a submarine he went out on campaigns on cruisers and then he became an aviator he first flew at the brescia air show in 1910 at which point the only flying machine in italy that could leave the ground all, could only rise one meter off the ground. In the ensuing four years, you know, technology had come on by leaps and bounds. So there were fighter planes. And Donizio never learned to pilot his own plane, but he would go
和飞行员一起坐上这些小型的双座飞机升空。而多尼齐奥会是那个把炸弹从机舱边扔下去的人。这字面意思就是扔下去。你拿起这个东西，然后把它从边上扔出去。当他进行这次飞越维也纳的著名空袭时，他投下了传单，不是吗？是的。但那是用意大利语写的，所以没人能看懂。是的，我的意思是，他坚信写作是一种武术。他坚信文字可以被武器化。所以他确实这么做了。
up in these little two-seaters with a pilot. And Donizio would be the man who dropped the bombs over the side. And it was literally a question of dropping them. You pick this thing up and you chuck it over the side. When he goes on this famous raid over Vienna, he drops pamphlets, doesn't he? Yes. But written in Italian, so nobody can understand them. Yeah, I mean, he believed in writing was a martial art. He believed that the word could be weaponized. And so he did.
首先，他飞越了被奥地利人占领的里雅斯特，在那里投下传单，说，你知道的，起来反抗你们的压迫者吧。你知道，我们意大利人来拯救你们了。然后，在战争的最后几个月里，这对意大利来说是一个相当绝望的时期，卡波雷托发生了可怕的失败。意大利人被逼退得几乎能在威尼斯听到枪声。但能让意大利人高兴起来的少数几件事情之一，就是多尼齐奥飞越奥地利首都维也纳的壮举。从威尼斯到维也纳对现代飞机来说是很短的一程，
First of all, he overflew Trieste, which was occupied by the Austrians, dropped pamphlets there saying, you know, rise up against your oppressors. You know, we Italians are coming to rescue you. And then in the last months of the war, which was a pretty desperate time for Italy, there'd been the terrible defeat at Caporetto. The Italians had been driven back almost to where you could hear the guns in Venice. But one of the few things that cheered Italians up was Donizio's flight over Vienna, the Austrian capital, of course. And Venice to Vienna is a very short hop for a modern plane,
但当时这是一次非常漫长的飞行。而且想必这是一次冒险的飞行。哦，非常冒险。我是说，最大的恐惧是，你能飞回来吗？因为，你知道，要在无法降落加油的情况下完成往返飞行，没有人真正知道这是否能做到。令人惊奇的是，他们确实飞回来了。但是是的，他在维也纳上空投下了这些传单，
but it was a very long flight then. And presumably a risky flight. Oh, so risky. I mean, the great fear was, could you make it back? Because, you know, to do the round trip without being able to land for refueling was nobody really knew whether it could be done. And amazingly, they did make it back. But yes, he dropped these pamphlets over Vienna,
正如你所说，可能没有人读这些传单或者根本没看懂。但这绝对对意大利的士气产生了巨大的影响。这看起来像是对奥地利人的一种极其大胆、勇敢的挑衅。看，我们在这儿。传单上写的是，这次我扔的是文字。下次我来的时候，我就会扔炸弹。所以想必这种壮举，它充满冲劲、好战、爱国、自负、超级男子气概，正是这一点让他随后能够完成他一生中最著名的插曲，也就是占领阜姆。那么这背后的故事是什么呢？因为这确实是故事的核心，不是吗？这是他在世界舞台上的高光时刻，绝对是的，而且呃
which possibly, as you say, nobody read the pamphlets or didn't understand them. But it certainly had a huge effect on Italian morale. It seemed such a kind of a bold, brave sort of up you to the Austrians. Look, here we are. And what the pap said was, this time I'm dropping words. Next time I come, I'll be dropping bombs. And so presumably this kind of exploit, it's dashing, it's militaristic, it's patriotic, it's swaggering, it's uber masculine, is what then enables him to carry off probably the most famous episode in his life which is the occupation of fiume so what's the story around that because really this is the heart of the story isn't it this was his his great moment on the world stage absolutely and uh so
阜姆现在叫里耶卡，在克罗地亚。Fiume和Rijeka在各自的语言中都是“河流”的意思。它是奥匈帝国匈牙利半部分的大港口。所以，你知道，维也纳有里雅斯特，布达佩斯有阜姆作为他们通往海洋的通道。因此它具有战略重要性，尽管它不是很大。它有大量意大利人口，因为来自意大利东海岸的意大利商人和海员会跨越亚得里亚海，与亚得里亚海海岸、达尔马提亚海岸的城市进行贸易。所以邓农齐奥认为所有这些城市，尤其是阜姆，应该变成意大利的领土，因为意大利在战争中是获胜的一方。实际上，这也是盟军向意大利承诺过的，即
fiume which is now called riecha it's in cro Croatia. Both Fiume and Rijeka mean river in their different languages. And it was the great port of the Hungarian half of the Austro-Hungarian Empire. So, you know, Vienna had Trieste and Budapest had Fiume as their access to the sea. So it was strategically important, although it's not very big. And it had a large Italian population because Italian merchants and seamen from the east coast of Italy would trade across the Adriatic to the cities on the Adriatic coast, on the Dalmatian coast. So D'Annunzio thought that all of those cities, but most particularly, if you may, should become Italian, because Italy had been on the winning side in the war. And really, that's what the Allies had promised Italy, that
那些达尔马提亚领土将成为多尼齐奥所说的大意大利的一部分。但事情变得比这更复杂。你知道，我很遗憾地说，盟军的表现糟透了。我是说，他们背信弃义，违背了协议，主要是因为他们根本没把意大利人当回事。正如多米尼克所说，你知道，意大利人经历了一场可怕的战争，实际上表现得极其勇敢、富于自我牺牲精神。但即便如此，你知道，在白厅和巴黎，你知道的外交官们还在拿冰淇淋小贩开玩笑。
those Dalmatian territories would become a part of what Donizio called the Greater Italy. But it all got more complicated than that. You know, I'm sorry to say that the Allies behaved appallingly. I mean, they went back on their agreement, largely because they just didn't take the Italians seriously. As Dominic said, you know, the Italians had gone through a terrible war and actually been extremely brave, self-sacrificing. But still, you know, in Whitehall and in Paris, you know, diplomats were making jokes about ice cream salesmen.
我是说，《凡尔赛条约》中非意大利参与者之间的信件是令人震惊的，他们谈论意大利人的方式。然而，讲述这个故事还有另一种方式，毫无疑问，那就是意大利人自己在背后捅了他们以前的伙伴一刀，表现得极其不光彩。诚然，他们与盟军签署了协议。但在战争结束时，特别是在美国人带着威尔逊和他的十四点原则以及民族自决权介入之后，总会有一个非常艰难的决定要在那里做出，
I mean, the correspondence between the non-Italian participants in the Treaty of Versailles are shocking, the way they talk about the Italians. There's another way of telling that story, though, surely, which is that the Italians had themselves behaved disgracefully in stabbing their own previous partners in the back. Admittedly, they'd signed a deal with the Allies. But at the end of the war, particularly after the Americans got involved with Wilson and his 14 points and self-determination, there was always going to be a very difficult decision to be made there
因为显然那个新创建的，当时叫什么来着，塞尔维亚人、克罗地亚人和斯洛文尼亚人王国，我想他们是这么叫的，后来变成了南斯拉夫，他们也想要达尔马提亚海岸线。所以意大利可能永远无法得到它想要的全部。并且有这样一种，也许是因为它战前的文化太神经质了，并且带有一种民族主义的方式，1919年的那种反应是，每个人都某种程度上说，哎呀，我们被彻底肢解和羞辱了。这其中有一种不理性，不是吗？
because obviously the newly created, what was it called then, the Kingdom of Serbs, Croats and Slovenes, I think they called it, which became Yugoslavia, that they wanted the Dalmatian seaboard as well. So Italy was probably never going to get everything that it wanted. And there was this sort of, maybe because its pre-war culture had been so neurotic and in a sort of nationalist way, that reaction in 1919, where everybody sort of says, oh, golly, we've been completely mutilated and humiliated. And there's an irrationality to that, isn't there?
还是说我太亲斯拉夫人了？不，不，这完全是不理性的。达尔马提亚本该属于意大利是绝对没有道理的。但邓农齐奥认为它应该属于意大利，他的同胞复国主义者们也是这么认为的，那些认为这些领土是伟大的旧意大利未收复失地的人也是这么想的。但是是的，你说得很对。存在着这样一个尴尬的新国家南斯拉夫，而伍德罗·威尔逊相当支持他们。所以多尼齐奥看到意大利无法得到它想要的东西。从1918年末的停战协议到1919年的春夏季，他与许多复国主义、民族主义、军国主义的意大利团体保持着联系，他们对正在发生的事情一点也不高兴，
Or am I being too pro-Slav? No, no, it's completely irrational. There's absolutely no reason why Dalmatia should have been Italian. But D'Annunzio thought it should, and so did his fellow irredentists, the people who thought those territories were the unredeemed parts of the old great Italy. But yes, you're quite right. There is this awkward new state, Yugoslavia, and Woodrow Wilson is rather in favor of them. And so Donizio sees that Italy is not going to get what it wants. From the armistice in late 1918 through the spring and summer of 1919, he's in touch with a lot of the sort of irredentist, nationalist, militarist Italian groups who are not happy at all about what's going on
并且觉得意大利受到了短斤少两的待遇。所以最终在8月份，阜姆的历史非常非常复杂，我认为我们无法深入探讨，但在阜姆有一群人决定他们想让它变成意大利的一部分，他们想要一个前台人物。所以这最初并不是多尼齐奥的主意。他们考虑了他们可能会邀请的各种人，然后他们决定，不，你知道的，多尼齐奥才是我们的人。他们来到威尼斯见他，他当时住在那里，整个战争期间他一直住在那里。他们对他说，来阜姆吧，来领导我们。他犹豫了
and the way they feel that Italy has been shortchanged. And so eventually, in August, the history of Fiume is very, very complex, and I don't think we can go into it, but there's a group of people in Fiume who decide that they would like to make it Italian, and they want a frontman. So this isn't initially Donizio's idea. And they think of, you know, various people they might invite, and then they decide, no, you know, Donizio's our guy. And they come to see him in Venice, where he's living, where he's been living throughout the war. And they say, come to Fiume, come and lead us. And he dithers
几天。他被邀请去参加一个相当精彩的聚会，他不想错过。他去参加了那个聚会。那是一个音乐晚会。他诱惑了那位女钢琴家，而她实际上在接下来的几年里一直做他的情妇。所以那是一个过得很充实的夜晚。但第二天他说，好吧，我要去了。他出发了，有一群来自意大利军队的叛军，共200人，驻扎在威尼斯正北方的龙基。他在半夜与他们会合，他们驾车穿过伊斯特拉半岛，向阜姆方向驶去，最终到达了那里。此时的多尼齐奥正发着高烧，记住这是1919年的西班牙流感，数百万人正在死去，他实际上站不起来，必须有人扶着他下车。所以这场本应是意气风发的进军，实际上是一个病得很重的人。
for a few days. And he's been invited to a rather wonderful party, which he doesn't want to miss. And he goes to the party. It's a musical soiree. And he seduces the pianist, who actually then remains his mistress for the next few years. So that was an evening well spent. But then the next day he says, all right, I'm coming. And he sets off and there are some mutineers from the Italian army, 200 of them based at Ronchi, which is just north of Venice. And he meets up with them in the middle of the night and they drive through Istria and down towards Fiume and they finally arrive there. Donizio by this time is running a very high temperature and remember this is 1919 Spanish flu people are dying in their millions and he could he actually can't stand up he has to be helped out of his car so what's supposed to be this dashing sort of advance is actually a very sick man.
待几天。他受邀去参加一个相当精彩的聚会，他不想错过。于是他去了派对。那是一个音乐晚会。他诱惑了那位女钢琴家，而她实际上在接下来的几年里成了他的情妇。所以那个晚上过得很有意义。但第二天他说，好吧，我来了。于是他动身出发，遇到了来自意大利军队的一些叛军，其中有两00人驻扎在威尼斯正北方的龙基。他在半夜与他们会合，他们穿过伊斯特拉半岛，朝阜姆方向驶去，最终到达了那里。此时邓南遮正发着高烧，记住这是1919年西班牙流感肆虐的时期，数以百万计的人在死去，他甚至无法站立，必须被人搀扶着走下汽车，所以这场本应意气风发的所谓突击，实际上是由一个病入膏肓的人进行的。
It's a bit like Byron going to Missolonghi. Yes. It's the name. I mean, Byron was sick and Danunzio was sick, but it's just the glamour of his name. Well, Danunzio possessed a ring, which he claimed rather probably had belonged to Byron. He liked to see himself as the new Boweren, so well spotted, yeah. I've skipped the fact that he had to advance through an Allied army, which was sort of, as it were, lying across the road in the Istrian peninsula.
这有点像拜伦去米索隆吉。是的。这就是名字的力量。我的意思是，拜伦生病了，邓南津也生病了，但这只是他名字的魅力所在。嗯，邓南津拥有一枚戒指，他声称这枚戒指很有可能是拜伦的。他喜欢把自己看作是新的拜伦，所以观察得很仔细，没错。我跳过了这样一个事实，即他必须穿过盟军军队，这支军队当时就横卧在伊斯特里亚半岛的道路上。
And they were under strict orders because the Allied hide command had got wind of the fact that Donizio was about to try and take over Fiume in this sort of maverick operation. And that was seen as being very disruptive and, you know, couldn't be allowed. So this Allied army was all under orders, if they saw Donizio and his followers, to shoot him dead. But it was an Italian army, although under Allied high command, and of course a large proportion of the Italian military were very much in favor of what D'Orenzio was doing. So as he arrived, sort of lying on the back seat of his enormous red motor car, and instead of shooting him dead, they just laid down their weapons and a lot of them followed him to Fiume.
他们接到了严格的命令，因为盟军最高指挥部风闻邓南津将要在这次类似非主流的行动中试图接管菲乌梅。这被认为是非常具有破坏性的，你知道的，是绝对不允许的。因此，这支同盟国军队都接到命令，如果看到邓南津和他的追随者，就将其当场击毙。但这是一支意大利军队，虽然受盟军最高指挥部指挥，当然，很大一部分意大利军人非常赞同邓南津正在做的事情。因此，当他抵达时，可以说是躺在他那辆巨大的红色汽车的后座上，他们不仅没有把他击毙，反而放下武器，其中很多人跟着他去了菲乌梅。
So he set off with 200 people, arrived there with over 2,000, which was soon augmented by many more thousands of volunteers. People from all over Europe wanted to join in Fiume. It seemed like a very exciting adventure that was going on there. And it wasn't just an Italian nationalist adventure. Donizio, when he arrived, declared that this was going to be a kind of, not just a piece of disputed territory, it was going to be an ideal state, a state of poetry, a state of beauty, where people would be freer and more loving and more beautiful than ever before. So there's a group of people, the Union of Free Spirits, tending towards perfection.
因此，他带着200人出发，到达那里时已有2,000多人，随后很快又增添了数千名志愿者。来自欧洲各地的人都想加入菲乌梅。在那里的似乎是一场非常令人兴奋的冒险。这不仅仅是一场意大利民族主义的冒险。邓南津刚到时就宣布，这不仅是一片有争议的领土，而且将成为一个理想国，一个诗歌之国，一个美之国，在那里人们将比以往任何时候都更加自由、充满爱意和美丽。所以有一群人，自由精神联盟，正朝着完美迈进。
That's right. Oh, yes, they were great. They believed in free love and no money. They were going to abolish money. I'm not quite sure what they were going to put in it. But there were all these political sects. And so there are the less well-known ones like that one. But there were there were all these political sects and so there are the less well-known ones like that one but there were also of course Bolsheviks Lenin was very much in favor of what Donizio was doing he sent him caviar doesn't he yes yes because of course if you're a Russian dictator you send caviar but he also said Donizio was the only true revolutionary in Europe but isn't there an argument that's what what he sets up in Fiume for the next 15 months or so? So he ignores all attempts to get him out, even the Italian government basically want him out. They organize a plebiscite, which he ignores.
没错。哦，是的，他们很棒。他们相信自由恋爱，没有金钱。他们打算废除货币。我不太确定他们打算用什么来取代它。但有所有这些政治流派。所以有一些不那么出名的派别，比如那个。但也有当然还有布尔什维克，列宁非常支持邓南津正在做的事情，他给他寄了鱼子酱，不是吗？是的，是的，因为当然，如果你是一个俄罗斯独裁者，你就会送鱼子酱，但他也说邓南津是欧洲唯一的真正的革命者。难道没有一种争论认为，这就是他在接下来大约15个月里在菲乌梅建立的东西吗？因此，他无视所有让他离开的企图，甚至意大利政府基本上也想让他离开。他们组织了一场全民公投，但他置之不理。
And he basically calls himself the Commandant. He spends his time either taking loads of coke or standing on the balcony kind of addressing and he's got the black uniform hasn't he and there's black uniforms he's called the commandant i mean so in some ways this looks like i mean it's funny that you said he arrived feverish because it's like a kind of fascistic fever dream isn't it of what an ideal sort of state but it's like it looks like a kind of 1970s visconti film about fascism where everybody's naked and having orgies and taking national play at the national theater yeah exactly that's exactly what it is isn't it i mean i mean so should we see the fumé story as this comic opera interlude or is it something much
他基本上自称为司令官。他把时间花在吸食大量可卡因或站在阳台上发表讲话上，他穿着黑色的制服，对吧，到处都是黑色的制服，他被称为司令官。我的意思是，在某些方面这看起来像——有趣的是你说他到时带着狂热，因为这就像是对理想国家的一种法西斯式的狂热之梦，不是吗？但它看起来像是某种20世纪70年代维斯康蒂关于法西斯的电影，每个人都赤身裸体，举行狂欢，还在国家剧院进行民族戏剧演出。是的，完全是这样，这不正是它的写照吗？我的意思是，我们究竟应该把菲乌梅的故事看作是一场喜歌剧式的插曲，还是某种更加...
more sinister because it's obviously anticipating and it's contempt for kind of legal norms it's obviously contemptuous of the slavs but also the worship of kind of its contempt for kind of legal norms. It's obviously contemptuous of the Slavs, but also the worship of kind of the contempt for sort of established institutions, but the belief in creating new ones, the worship of violence and of action and spectacle and all that. I mean, this all feels immensely fascistic to me. Definitely, I quite agree. And it's not comic opera, but it's certainly theatre. And Donizio would come out onto the balcony. He'd taken over the old Habsburg governor's palace in the centre of the town, just this sort of fan-shaped square. So it's like an amphitheatre. He would stand on the balcony
更加险恶的事情，因为它显然预示并蔑视了某种法律规范，它显然蔑视斯拉夫人的同时，也崇拜并蔑视某种既定机构，但它坚信建立新的机构，崇拜暴力、行动和奇观等等。我的意思是，这一切让我感觉无比的法西斯化。当然，我完全同意。这不是喜歌剧，但它绝对是戏剧。邓南津会走到阳台上。他接管了市中心的哈布斯堡王朝总督府，这里是一个扇形广场。所以它就像一个圆形剧场。他会站在阳台上
and he would launch into these speeches, which weren't exactly speeches, they were dialogues with the crowd. So he'd be going, you know, what do we want? We want Fiume, what do we want? Fiume or death, and so on and so forth. And he would be working the people up into a frenzy of excitement. And he would lead them around the city and up into the mountains behind in great processions, and they'd be singing,ting out uh giovannetta which became the great fascist anthem giovannetta meaning youth donizio is by this time 57 but he called himself the prince
他开始发表这些演讲，与其说是演讲，不如说是与人群的对话。所以他会问，你知道，我们想要什么？我们要菲乌梅，我们想要什么？菲乌梅还是死亡，诸如此类。他会把人们煽动到狂热的兴奋状态。他会带领他们游历城市，并在后面的山地中举行盛大的游行，他们会高歌，引吭高歌《青年曲》（Giovinezza），这后来成为了伟大的法西斯党歌，《青年曲》的意思就是青春。邓南津当时已经57岁了，但他自称为青年王子
of youth and then they would go down onto the waterfront where there was sort of open space by the docks where he would uh review his his legion as he called them. He saw himself as a new Julius Caesar by this point. And they were, a lot of them were ex-Arditi. And the Arditi were the kind of the Italian shock troops during World War I. They would go ahead, you know, before the regular troops tried to march on an enemy trench or defensive post, the Arditi would go ahead with just their bayonets, not carrying guns. And they died very fast. I mean, they were almost sort of sacrificing themselves. But those who survived saw themselves as absolutely the creme de la creme of the Italian army. And they weren't really subject to the usual rules because they were being asked to take such risks.
然后他们会走到水边，那里是码头边的开阔空间，他会在那里检阅他的军团，他自己是这么叫的。此时他把自己看作是新尤利西斯·恺萨。他们中很多人都是前突击队员（Arditi）。突击队员是一战期间意大利的某种突击部队。他们会走在前面，你知道的，在正规军试图向敌方战壕或防御工事发起冲锋之前，突击队员只拿着刺刀走在前面，不带枪。他们死得很快。我的意思是，他们几乎是在自我牺牲。但那些幸存下来的人认为自己绝对是意大利军队中的精英。他们并不真正受常规规则的约束，因为他们被要求承担如此巨大的风险。
And they had this very distinctive black uniform with the silver lightning flash. During the war, D'Annunzio often spoke specially to the Aditi. He was very excited by them, admiring of them. And they liked him. I mean, they felt that he got the point of them and he liked the way that he addressed them as the heroes of the war. And a lot of them followed him into Fiume. They didn't want to go home and be farm boys after the war ended. And so they were, as it were, his honor guard. And he would line them up down by the docks and review them. And it was there that he taught them the straight-armed salute,
他们有着非常醒目的黑色制服，上面带有银色闪电标志。战争期间，邓南津经常专门对突击队员发表讲话。他对他们感到非常兴奋并十分钦佩。他们也喜欢他。我的意思是，他们觉得他理解他们的点，并且喜欢他称他们为战争英雄的方式。他们中的很多人跟着他去了菲乌梅。战争结束后，他们不想回家当农夫。所以他们就像是他的仪仗队。他会把他们排在码头上并进行检阅。正是在那里，他教他们行直臂礼，
which would become the fascist salute. And a lot of those rituals became a part of fascism. And it wasn't just the rituals. There was a lot of ethnically determined bullying. So Fiume was a very divided city. There was a prosperous Italian merchant class, and there was a Slav working class who tended to live on the outskirts of the city and most of them the other side of the river. And as the months, Terenzio's era in Fiume lasted astonishingly for 15 months, but just because it didn't suit any of the great powers to
这将成为法西斯礼节。许多这样的仪式成为了法西斯主义的一部分。不仅是仪式，还有很多基于族裔的欺凌。因此，菲乌梅是一个分裂严重的城市。这里有一个繁荣的意大利商人阶层，还有一个斯拉夫工人阶级，他们往往住在城市的郊区，大部分在河的对岸。随着时间的推移，邓南津在菲乌梅的统治出人意料地持续了15个月，但这只是因为各大国都不适合联合起来把他赶出去，仅此而已。在此期间，该市遭到意大利政府的部分封锁，意大利政府对他的所作所为感到深切的尴尬。因此，他们开始感到非常饥饿。当然，当人们挨饿时，他们就会生气，就会发生骚乱。而这些骚乱具有了种族分化的性质。因此，菲乌梅的斯拉夫族人口被禁止获得食物。情况变得非常非常糟糕。所以，是的，起初可能看起来相当浪漫和理想主义的事情。它是理想主义的，但就像许多理想主义的冒险一样，它以一种非常糟糕的方式结束了。
get themselves together to boot him out, really. And in the course of that time, the city was partially blockaded by the Italian government, who were deeply embarrassed by what he was doing. And so they began to get very hungry. And of course, when people are hungry, they get angry and there are riots. And those riots became racially divided. And so the Slavic population of Fiume was being barred from getting food. It was becoming very, very ugly indeed. So that, yes, what may have started off as seeming rather romantic and idealistic. It was idealistic, but like a lot of idealistic ventures, it ended in a very ugly way.
最后，是意大利人把他赶了出去。是的。他回到威尼斯，最后来到加尔达湖。基本上，他在墨索里尼领导法西斯分子时隐退了。我们收到了大量关于邓南津与法西斯主义关系的问题。挑几个来回答。斯特凡·詹森（Stefan Jensen）问：邓南津发明了法西斯主义吗？哈里森·皮（Harrison Pee）问：邓南津式的法西斯主义与后来由墨索里尼和布雷赫特（译者注：此处可能指布雷特等其他独裁者，或原文口误）强加的法西斯主义有多大关系？你认为有什么论据表明他其实根本不是法西斯分子吗？我的意思是，为了做个总结，
In the end, it's the Italians who kick him out. Yes. And he goes back to Venice and then he ends up on Lake Garda. Essentially, he goes into retirement while Mussolini is then leading the fascists. And we've had loads of questions on the relationship between D'Annunzio and fascism. So just a few of them. Stefan Jensen, did D'Annunzio invent fascism? Harrison Pee, how closely does D'Annunzio's variety of fascism relate to the later fascism imposed by Mussolini and Brecht? Do you think there are any arguments to suggest he wasn't actually a fascist after all? I mean, just to kind of round things off,
你认为邓南津与法西斯主义的关系是什么？我认为他们采用了他的思想。他从未公开支持法西斯主义，或者说，在1919年，他走到米兰的阳台上，他认为那是——事后他觉得那是一个巨大的错误。他曾被法西斯分子邀请加入他们，但他从未公开赞成过他们。在菲乌梅之后，墨索里尼非常清楚，与邓南津相比，他（墨索里尼）的支持者非常少。邓南津是一个非常非常大的公众人物。而邓南津则退隐了。他去加尔达湖居住，住在一所他买下的房子里，那是一座非常普通、相当迷人的意大利农舍。然后他着手把它变成一个非凡的陵墓和一件为颂扬他自己而创作的装置艺术品。
what do you see D'Annunzio's relationship to fascism as being? I think that they took his ideas. He never endorsed fascism publicly, or he, in 1919, he went out onto the balcony in Milan, and he thought that was, afterwards he felt that was a great mistake. He was invited by the fascists to join them, but he never spoke in favor of them. After Fiume, Mussolini was very well aware that he, Mussolini, had a very small following by comparison with Donizio's. Donizio was a big, big public figure. And Donizio withdrew. He went to live on Lake Garda in a house that he, which was a perfectly ordinary, rather lovely Italian farmhouse when he bought it. And then he proceeded to turn it into this extraordinary mausoleum and a piece of installation art in celebration of himself.
墨索里尼一直意识到邓南津可能会突然重新出现在政治舞台上。确实有一些时刻，人们走近他，暗示他可能希望这样做，但他没有。我认为他在菲乌梅事件之后有点失去了勇气。他感到非常非常沮丧，因为他认为自己是意大利的英雄，但突然有一艘意大利军舰出现在菲乌梅港，向这座城市发射了一枚导弹，随后他花了几天才投降并同意离开。这确实摧毁了他对自己作为意大利民族化身的信心。
And Mussolini was always aware that Donizio might suddenly reappear on the political stage. And there were certainly moments when people approached him suggesting that he might wish to do so but he didn't i think that he's kind of lost his nerve after fume he was very very distressed by the fact that it was he saw himself as an italian hero but it was an italian warship that suddenly appeared in the harbor at fume and fired a missile into the city at at which point it took a few days, but he capitulated and agreed to leave. And that really destroyed his confidence in himself as the embodiment of the Italian race.
我会说邓南津不是法西斯分子，但法西斯主义绝对是邓南津的。这是我对这件事的口头禅。你认为他……另一个问题是，道格拉斯·安德鲁斯（Douglas Andrews）问：如果在20世纪20年代，是邓南津而不是墨索里尼领导法西斯分子在意大利上台，会有什么不同？我的意思是，有一个时刻，不是吗，
I would say that D'Annunzio wasn't a fascist, but fascism was definitely D'Annunzio. It's my catchphrase on that. Do you think he... One of the other questions is, Douglas Andrews, if D'Annunzio rather than Mussolini had led the fascists into power in Italy in the 1920s, what would have been different? I mean, there is a moment, isn't there,
在1919年、1920年的故事中，第一次世界大战结束时意大利陷入了如此严重的经济混乱，被黑衫军（squadristi）和布尔什维克之间的战斗等等撕裂。很多人，有很多关于邓南津成为独裁者的讨论。被黑衫军和布尔什维克之间的战斗等等撕裂。很多人，有很多关于邓南津成为独裁者的讨论。你认为这是一种可能吗？如果他真的这样做了，你认为它会朝着类似墨索里尼的方向发展吗？
in the story about 1919, 1920, when Italy is in such an economic mess at the end of the First World War, it's torn apart by the fighting between the kind of squadristi and Bolsheviks and stuff. And lots of people, there's lots of talk of D'Annunzio becoming a dictator. by the fighting between the kind of squadristi and Bolsheviks and stuff. And lots of people, there's lots of talk of Donizio becoming a dictator. Do you think that was a possibility? And if he had done so, do you think it would have gone in a kind of Mussolini-like direction?
还是说他太像个业余爱好者而不会发生这种事？我认为这很容易发生。而且肯定有人希望发生这种事，他们，你知道的，邀请他在双方阵营中挺身而出。我的意思是，有些人认为他无论如何会比墨索里尼更文明一点，更温和。而另一些人则认为他可能会更极端。我的意思是，当墨索里尼试图让自己与黑衫军以及法西斯头几年的极端暴力保持距离时。有些人认为墨索里尼变得太软弱了，认为也许邓南津可以回来变得更加暴力。但事实是，我认为他从来都不感兴趣。我觉得他喜欢率领他的军团抵达菲乌梅，
Or was he too much of a dilettante for that to happen? I think it could easily have happened. And there were certainly people who wanted it to happen, who were, you know, inviting him to step forth on both sides. I mean, people who thought that he would be, well, a bit more civilized than Mussolini anyway, more moderate. And other people who thought he might be more extreme. I mean, when Mussolini tried to distance himself from the squadristi and the, you know, the extreme violence of the first fascist years. And there were some people who thought Mussolini was getting too soft and thought maybe the Nazi could come back and be more violent. But the truth is, I don't think he was ever interested. I think he loved arriving in Fiume at the head of his legion
以及所有的戏剧性场面、歌声、戏剧和兴奋感。但实际上，他对政府一点也不感兴趣。你知道的，他不想去考虑税收和……无聊。无聊。是的。是的。所以他一直活到30年代。他在……去世，显然在第二次世界大战中发生的事情是，法西斯主义无可救药地被视为某种邪恶、罪恶和阴险的东西，所以我对哈罗德·斯塔森（Harold Stassen）提出的问题非常感兴趣，那就是今天在意大利人们是如何看待邓南津的。每当我去意大利旅行时，我似乎总是发现自己走在一条以他的名字命名的街道上。所以邓南津在意大利并没有被“取消”，对吧？不，绝对没有。但实际上他曾被取消过。在40年代末、50年代的某个时期，意大利人在第二次世界大战和法西斯政权结束后，
and all the drama of it and and the singing, and the theatre, and the excitement. But actually, he wasn't at all interested in government. You know, he didn't want to have to think about taxes and... Boring. Boring. Yeah. Yeah. So he lives all the way through the 30s. He dies in um and obviously what happens in the second world war fascism is is irredeemably seen as something wicked and evil and sinister and so i'm very interested question that harold stassen asks which is how is denuncio thought of in italy today whenever i've been on a trip to italy i seem to find myself walking down a street named after him. So Donizio has not been cancelled, as it were, in Italy. No, absolutely not. But he was, actually. In the kind of late 40s, 50s, Italians had a difficult
面对着一个沉重的历史包袱。曾有一段时间，邓南津的存在感远不如现在。但现在，他早期的诗歌非常美丽，无疑是课程的一部分。每一个学习意大利文学超过一定程度的学童都会读到邓南津的一些早期抒情诗。人们就是这样记住他的。你知道的，当我研究我的书并第一次去他在加尔达湖的房子时，我非常震惊地意识到，它在多大程度上过去是、现在仍然是极右翼的朝圣地。
legacy to cope with after the end of the fascist regime and the end of the Second World War. And there was a time when Donizio was much less visible than he is now. But now certainly his early poems, which are beautiful, very much part of the curriculum. Every school child who is studying Italian literature beyond a certain point will have read some of Donizio's early lyrics. He's remembered like that. You know, when I was researching my book and I first went to his house on Lake Garda, I was quite startled to realise to what extent it was and still is a place of pilgrimage for the extreme right.
所以他依然受到那些与他持有相同政治观点的人的崇拜，这让人感到担忧。露西，非常感谢。这是一本绝对荣获大奖、极其出色的书。我的意思是，简直让人爱不释手。确实如此。事实上，我们还没有提到的一点是，除了所有其他优点之外，这本书之所以如此精彩，是因为它并不枯燥，你知道的，从第1页到第600页，从摇篮到坟墓的传统传记。这是一本某种程度上重塑了传记艺术的书，对吧，汤姆？确实如此。这就是《长矛》（The Pike）。是的。
So he's still admired by people who share his political views, which is alarming. Lucy, thanks so much. That was absolute prize winning, brilliant book. I mean, just compulsively readable. It is. And actually, what we haven't said about it is that it's what makes it such a wonderful book, apart from all the other things, is that it's not boring, you know, page one to page 600, cradle to grave biography. It's a book that kind of reinvents the art of biography, isn't it, Tom? It really is. So that's The Pike. Yeah.
露西·休斯-哈利特（Lucy Hughes Hallett）。露西，非常感谢。谢谢大家的收听。我们很快就会回来。再见。谢谢你，露西。再见。谢谢。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前解锁、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Lucy Hughes Hallett. Lucy, thanks so much. Thanks to everyone for listening. And we'll be back soon. Bye bye. Thank you, Lucy. Bye bye. Thank you. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
该内容暂无评论